am 24 februar jährt sich Wladimir Putins
Überfall auf die Ukraine seitdem ist die
Friedensordnung auf dem Kontinent
zerstört eine Friedensordnung die lange
Bestand hatte die dem Kalten Krieg stand
hielt und die nach dem Zusammenbruch es
soweit Imperiums Hoffnung für den
Kontinent verheißt diese Friedensordnung
liegt in ukrainischem Schutt und in der
ukrainische Asche zerbomben von Putins
Aggression und die Frage war und ist nun
wie kann dieser Krieg beendet werden und
damit begrüße ich Sie bei unter den
Linken
[Musik]
und ich begrüße hier bei uns Thomas
Heilmann Mitglied der cdu/csu-fraktion
im Deutschen Bundestag und ehemaliger
Justizsenator hier in Berlin und ich
begrüße sehr herzlich Professor Söhnke
Neitzel Historiker mit Schwerpunkt
Militärgeschichte von der Uni Potsdam
herzlich Willkommen an sie beide
Heilmann sie sind Bundestagsabgeordneter
aber hier aus Berlin waren wie ich eben
schon sagte Justizsenator hier in Berlin
für längere Zeit sie könnten Berlin
gestern hat Berlin gewählt sie kommen
gerade aus dem Landesvorstand auch der
CDU CDU ist stärkste Partei geworden
liegt weiter vor den anderen wie groß
ist denn die Hoffnung dass sie auch in
der Regierungsbildung beteiligt sind
also wir als CDU-Politiker hoffen dass
natürlich weil man als Partei ja in der
politischen Willensbildung mitwirken
will und auch ein Wahlergebnis in
Regierungsverantwortung umwandeln will
aber dass das was die CDU will
ich glaube es wichtig zu verstehen dass
die Stadt droht zu spalten und keine
kann sehr für sich keine Seite kann für
sich in Anspruch nehmen wirklich für die
Mehrheit und immer für die Hälfte der
Berliner zu reden die jetzige Koalition
hat etwa 35% der Wahlberechtigten von
sich überzeugt also derjenigen die
wirklich ihnen eine Stimme gegeben hat
natürlich ist die CDU auch weit weg von
einer auch nur der Hälfte und es wäre
glaube ich sehr gut für die Stadt wenn
die großen Konflikte Themen Klima
Wohnungsbau Verkehr wenn wir da
Kompromisse finden und eine Brücke
finden ich glaube es wir sehr im
Interesse der Stadt und ist ja auch gar
nicht das deutsche volksmodell dass wir
am harten Wahlkampf dann gemeinsam etwas
hinbekommen ob das in Berlin gelingt das
ist zu früh nach großer Koalition so oft
wie sie das Wort groß jetzt auch benutzt
hat also da da ist ja zwei gleich große
Zweitplatzierte gibt mit den Grünen und
der SPD ist ist das genauso groß und
genauso kleine aber jetzt mit den Grünen
und der SPD ist heute auch keinen Fall
ein kann sein das ist jetzt glaube ich
auch nicht die Meinung der CDU wir sind
da glaube ich in beide Richtungen offen
kommt jetzt auf die Gespräche an
wenn man im Vorfeld sich die Umfragen
angeschaut hat dann war das Thema
Sicherheit eines der ganz großen Themen
das ging dabei natürlich um die innere
Sicherheit und jetzt gar nicht unbedingt
um den Krieg in der Uhr keine ich möchte
trotzdem Nachfragen sie kennen die Stadt
hat der Krieg in Russland und der Krieg
in der Ukraine irgendein Einfluss gehabt
auf das Wählerverhalten
erstaunlich wenig weil die Linkspartei
hat verloren Stimmen verloren aber doch
weniger angesichts des jahrhundert
mentalen Streit ist an der
Bundestagsfraktion um die Frage sind wir
jetzt eigentlich russlandfreundlich
trotz des Krieges oder nicht es gibt ja
richtig tiefgehende Spannung das hat
sich kaum ausgewirkt man kann sagen sehr
indirekt die Wohnungsnot ist natürlich
durch die jetzt ansteigenden
Flüchtlingszahlen auch nochmal größer
geworden und das hat eine Rolle gespielt
wenn wir uns das Anschauen das wir jetzt
seit knapp einem Jahr Kriege in der
Ukraine haben und wir hören gerade das
ist eigentlich kein großen Einfluss bei
diesen Wahlen gegeben hat gehen Sie
davon aus dass vorbei und wenn die
Wahlen jetzt ich sag mal vor 11 Monaten
gewesen wären dass das eine sehr viel
größere Rolle gespielt hat also anders
gefragt gibt es so eine Art
Gewöhnungseffekt an diesen Kriegen
also ich glaube ich bin kein
Parteienforscher aber ich glaube in der
Zeit das war dieser Landtagswahl jetzt
eher Berliner Themen im Vordergrund
standen was anderes wäre das glaube ich
wenn jetzt Bundestagswahl wäre und auf
dem Bundesebene ist glaube ich schon
dann die Frage
wie sich eine Bundesregierung in ihrer
Außenpolitik verhält und man merkt ja
wie die SPD ja ähm auch die SPD
vielleicht am meisten gespalten ist wie
wird man Russland bekämpfen soll oder
nicht bekämpfen soll und und ein
Mittelweg findet wir sehen ja auch in
den Umfragen dass eben ein Teil der der
BundesbürgerInnen und Bürger eben er
zögerlich ist Angst hat oder gleich aber
das ist glaube ich eher etwas für eine
Bundesebene und hier in Berlin war das
natürlich meine ich lebe auch hier in
dieser Stadt da gibt es sehr Berliner
Berliner Themen Verkehr Wohnungen dass
die Wahl eben verbaselt wurde das stimmt
aber wahrscheinlich stärker im
Vordergrund einiger Krieg heißt das denn
dass wir uns auch ein Stück weit dran
gewöhnt haben
ich glaube schon also es gibt sicherlich
Gewöhnungseffekte wie wir das bei der
kobold-pandemie auch schon gesehen haben
bei allen anderen Themen und wenn wir
noch ist ja an mir selber sehe ich dass
wenn ich zurückdenke in den Februar an
den März wie wir glaube ich alle vor dem
Fernseher gebannt saßen und dachten wann
fällt Kiew und und welche Dynamik nimmt
das
und jetzt kann man schon die Lage ein
bisschen mehr sagen abschätzen man merkt
das Leben geht weiter man merkt auch
dass die deutsche Volkswirtschaft das
überlebt hat es gab ja auch viele
Prognosen dass das alles völlig
zusammenbricht man hat diesen Winter
einigermaßen gut überstanden also da
gibt's ein Gewöhnungseffekt
und man hat auch immer wieder auch jetzt
die Meinung jetzt muss aber die kriegt
eigentlich immer Enden also jetzt lieber
mit 14 Leopard Panzer aber jetzt muss
sein also jetzt muss der kriegt auch
jetzt verhandeln und so weiter
also auch
viele Aufrufe kriegen ja in diese
Richtung und ob wir wirklich
in der Realität angekommen sind ob wir
wirklich verstehen was da so
funktioniert auch langfristig da kann
man zumindest bei einem Teil der
bundesbürgerin noch in Fragezeichen
machen
wenn wir uns diesen Gewöhnungseffekt mal
ein Stück weit näher angucken bedeutet
das gleichzeitig auch Kriegsmüdigkeit
also ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was der
Gegenstück zu Kriegsmüdigkeit also
irgendein hurra habe ich zu diesem Krieg
von noch niemanden gehört
unterstützungsbereitschaft
Aufmerksamkeit in diese Richtung mehr
also wie niemand sehr viel größer als
sie im Moment ist das weiß ich gar nicht
weil weil der Gewöhnungseffekt gerade
angesprochen hat der zeigt natürlich
auch wir können uns diese Unterstützung
der Ukraine leisten ohne dass hier
irgendwie alles zusammenbricht
die unpopuläre Botschaft die jedenfalls
ich auch sagen würde ist wir müssen
leider davon ausgehen dass Putin möchte
dass der Krieg ganz lange dauert weil
jedes Ende des kriegerische Putin eine
große Gefahr ist ist die ganze Ukraine
beherrschen und hätte dann für immer
Ruhe an der Front das ist kaum
vorstellbar wie das gelingen soll für
ihn und dann ist für ihn eine
langjährige Auseinandersetzung die ihr
ja auch in Georgien in Syrien und so
also er hat ja bewiesen dass dass er
bereit ist auch 10 Jahre zu investieren
und wir müssen uns leider darauf
einstellen dass er das in der Ukraine
auch sein könnte
dauert also lange wenn wir Umfragen hier
in Deutschland uns anschauen dann sind
zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung bereit in
Falle eines Angriffs mit der Waffe ihr
Land auch tatsächlich zu verteidigen wie
ist diese Zahl einzuschätzen ist das
viel oder ist das wenig
also erstmal würde ich mir natürlich
wünschen dass es mehr werden denn ich
glaube also aus meiner Sicht ist ja
eigentlich der Gesellschaftsvertrag dass
der Staats den Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Freiheit gewährt dass er in
Rechtssicherheit gewährt dass er eine
freie liberale Wirtschaftsordnung
gewährt aber das die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger diesen Staat auch schützen müssen
in einem Extremfall so ist eigentlich
immer seit Gründung der Bundeswehr ich
sage immer der Deal gewesen und wenn die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sagen der Stadt
schon ganz schön und hier zu leben man
lebt auch lieber in Deutschland als
woanders aber ja schützen wollen wir den
Staat eigentlich nicht das ist uns dann
zu viel diese Diskussion gab es ja auch
einen kalten Krieg es sich eigentlich
ein bisschen traurig weil ein Extremfall
sollten wir schon für diese Staatswesen
diese liberale Demokratie diese diese
Republik auch versuchen sie am Leben zu
halten
auf der anderen Seite mit diesen
Umfragen ist es natürlich so eine Sache
denn der Krieg ist nach wie vor glaube
ich weit weg wir sehen es am Fernsehen
wir sehen natürlich die ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge aber natürlich stehen die
russischen Streitkräfte nicht an den
seelowerhöhen und ich glaube wenn eine
unmittelbare Bedrohung da wäre auch
alleinwände der Krieg auf nato-terre
Touren übergreifen würde wäre noch mal
eine andere Situation aber trotzdem dann
glaube ich auch nicht dass dann 90%
bereit wären ich glaube schon das ist
auch das Produkt
unseres Umgangs mit Militär ist und auch
vor allen Dingen der letzten 30 Jahre
und wir haben ja seit 1990 gedacht also
kriegt gibt's ja irgendwie nicht mehr
und das müssen wir auch nicht nur dass
wir nicht führen sondern auch alle
anderen führen ihn nicht mehr und wir
haben eigentlich gelernt Kriege zu lesen
verlernt Kriege zu lesen und wir haben
Krieg aus dem referenzraum von Politik
und Gesellschaft
und ihn wieder rein obwohl er stattfand
in Jugoslawien in Tschetschenien in
Syrien sie haben es angesprochen
Afghanistan ob wir selber ja auch eine
defacto kriegt für eine Partei waren in
Afghanistan und im Kosovo aber es war
hier nicht wirklich präsent das war also
nicht nicht on als gesellschaftliches
Thema auch nicht in der Politik also mit
aus dem Sicherheitspolitik hat man keine
Wahlkämpfe geführt und nicht die CDU war
jetzt
endlich mal aus meiner Sicht eine
Parteien in dem letzten Wahlkampf
Bundestagswahlkampf aus dem
Sicherheitspolitik ganz nach vorne
gestellt und im Wahlprogramm das ist
schon außergewöhnlich gewesen für eine
Partei
aber das ist wieder zurückzubringen und
sagen wir müssen da realistischer werden
das ist glaube ich ein langer Prozess
jetzt haben wir ein Jahr Krieg und wir
müssen jetzt sehen bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl wie weit sich auch die
politische Kultur verändert hatte in
diesem Land ich glaube schon dass wir
auf dem Weg dahin sind denn wer hätte
vor einem Jahr gedacht dass 70 Prozent
der Grünen Wähler für Panzerlieferungen
sein werden jemals und zwar wesentlich
mehr als Fehler der cdu/csu nicht und da
hat sich glaube ich schon was verschoben
aber wie weit das wirklich übersetzt
wird in eine politische Kultur auch eine
andere Sichtweise der Bundeswehr Organ
eine Bereitschaft selber ja
Opfer zu bringen selber also wir sagen
einige meiner Galeristen Freunde sie
würden heute den Wehrdienst nicht mehr
verweigern Angesicht da würde ich gerne
würde ich gerne anknüpfen äh Heilmann
Stichwort wirklich die wurde abgeschafft
es gibt jetzt einige die durchaus danach
widerrufen dass sie wieder eingeführt
werden muss auch werden vielleicht um
Kultur wieder ein Stück weit einzuführen
und es näher an die Gesellschaft ran zu
bringen ist das notwendig
ich hoffe nicht ich glaube im Moment
wäre die Bundeswehr auch überhaupt nicht
in der Lage eine Wehrpflicht
durchzuführen organisatorisch nicht
militärisch nicht von ihrer Ausstattung
nicht
eine der Gründe warum wir die
Wehrpflicht ja ausgesetzt haben war dass
ein Krieg immer technischer wird immer
komplexer in der Anwendung die
Ausbildung wenn sie sinnvoll sein soll
auch immer länger dauert und genau das
was Putin im Moment macht haben wir uns
ja nicht mehr vorstellen können dass man
so richtigen Verschleiß Krieg führt bei
der ich sagen werde um Welle von
Soldaten ins Gefecht schieße und ich
schicke und damit sehr viele auch
erschossen werden das habe ich mir nicht
vorstellen können ich glaube wichtig ist
folgender Gedanke umso besser man
vorbereitet ist umso mehr man
glaubwürdig sagen kann wir verteidigen
uns umso weniger findet statt
wenn die Ukraine besser gerüstet gewesen
wäre wenn wir Westen Ihnen rechtzeitig
geholfen hätte hätte sich Putin
wahrscheinlich dreimal überlegt ob er
das wirklich macht er ist ja
offensichtlich von einer kompletten
fehlereinschätzung ausgegangen über den
Vorbereitungsstand und diese
Fehleinschätzung die darf es eben nicht
geben
für die gesamte NATO nicht und
eigentlich auch sonstige befreundete
Länder wieder Ukraine eben nicht
der Verteidigungsminister hat neulich
mal gesagt das ist ein Fehler war die
Wehrpflicht abzuschaffen würden sie ihm
dazu stimmen jetzt vor allen Dingen in
der im Rückblick
ich glaube das war eher ein Fehler dass
wir den Umbau nicht richtig finanziert
haben also wir haben eine
Friedensdividende gezogen die Bundeswehr
mit dem Aussetzen der Wehrpflicht
finanziell stark gekappt und im
Nachhinein ist man ja immer schlauer
hätten wir sagen müssen wir bauen um
aber wir bauen eine richtig gute
Berufsarmee auf die auch top
ausgestattet ist dann hätten wir glaube
ich jetzt auch weniger Diskussionen man
muss immer sagen eine Wehrpflicht ist
ein massiver Grundrechtseingriff für die
jungen Männer oder wir machen sie in
Israel dass wir die Frauen auch
einziehen
die muss man sich glaube ich sehr genau
überlegen also ich wäre jedenfalls stand
heute nicht bereit als Bundestag aber
sozusagen wir brauchen noch die
Wehrpflicht aber
wer weiß wie aggressiv Russland noch
wird ich finde das leider nicht für alle
Zeiten ausschließen aber heute will ich
das militärhistorikers was für eine
Aufgabe hat denn auch die Wehrpflicht
wenn man die Gesellschaft betrachtet und
war die Abschaffung aus ihrer sichten
Fehler in Ihrer Frage schwingt es so ein
bisschen mit die Zivil militärischen
Beziehungen man immer sagt er also wenn
man Wehrpflicht hat der Bürger und
Uniform Staatsbürger und Uniform so ein
Credo der Bundeswehr ja sie sprachen ja
die Kultur an auch ein Stück
weitere ist man enger zusammen an allen
Familien Erfahrungen das ist schon
richtig aber
de facto war 2011 bei der Aussetzung der
Wehrpflicht die wäre vielleicht
eigentlich tot und ich erinnere mich an
meiner eine Zeit damals war ich an der
Uni Mainz wenn ich mal ein Seminar
fragte werde von euch warte mal der
Bundeswehr also kurz Voraussetzung
niemand wer kennt denn von Euch jemand
der bei der Bundeswehr war auch niemand
du bist auf einem halben also selber
Offizier oder so also der Faktor war wir
hatten lange Zeit neun Monate
Wehrpflicht dann 6 Monate also der
Faktor war das schon ausgesetzt und es
war eigentlich konsequent der Fehler war
dass man gleichzeitig die Strukturen
geschliffen hat um die Wehrpflicht
wieder einzuführen wir haben ja nur
ausgesetzt haben sie ja nicht
abgeschafft ich würde noch ich glaube
ein Punkt finde ich noch wichtiger wir
haben zugelassen dass die Bundeswehr
ausgegrenzt wurde aus unserer
Gesellschaft und das ist in jeder
Hinsicht also Militär darf keine sonder
abgekoppelte Einheit sein ja es müssen
Demokraten in Uniformen sein und
deswegen müssen sie in die Schulen nicht
weil sie da unbedingt alle so viele
Leute anwerben sollen sondern weil es so
wie wir Bundestagsabgeordnete in jeder
Schule willkommen sind ist auch richtig
ist es wieder hingehen
es ist eben auch wichtig dass das
Menschen merken das sind auch Menschen
so wie Polizisten auch in der Schule
sein sollten und die Schule ist jetzt
glaube ich nur Passwort toto
wir müssen die Bundeswehrsoldaten und
die Soldaten inzwischen
zum Teil unserer Gesellschaft machen was
auch davor schützt dass sie nicht
radikalisiert werden ich glaube es ist
nur ein Randbereich in ein Problem aber
das muss man ja auch langfristig
strategisch sein das ist glaube ich noch
viel wichtiger als jetzt die wirklich
der militärische Sinnhaftigkeit ich
glaube ich heute nicht gejagt wurde das
Problem mit den Schulen hat plötzlich
schon seit 1968 es gibt in den 70er
Jahren heftige Debatte es gibt Plädoyers
von
bisschen zu Kanzler Willy Brandt an die
Kultusministerkonferenz da müsste doch
mal die Schulen öffnen es gab natürlich
gerade in Hessen euch zur Schule
gegangen bin eine Tendenz die sehr
antibi Bundeswehr war aber das
Interessante ist dass wir seit 1990
eigentlich die Zustimmung der
Bevölkerung zeigen alle Umfragen zur
Bundeswehr zu den Soldaten hat nicht
gestiegen ist und die Höhe war als im
Kalten Krieg wir haben es aber im
politischen Bereich wir haben es im bei
den gesellschaftlichen Eliten
Universitäten da war sicherlich ein
großer eine große Kritik da und das
Licht hinwerflicht her also ich glaube
und dann einen Punkt vielleicht noch
weil das auch öfter so kommt mit
Abschaffung der Wehrpflicht
ist die Bundeswehr nicht mal Teil der
Gesellschaft da war mein Gegenargument
immer naja diese Leute kommen hier aus
der Gesellschaft und die sind ja dann
die meisten sind Zeitsoldaten die sind
dann was nicht zwischen zwei und 15
Jahren bei der Bundeswehr sie kommen aus
der Gesellschaft die sind hier zur
Schule gegangen die haben Frauen oder
Männer die haben Kinder in den
Kindergarten nehmen an der öffentlichen
Debatte teil und sie gehen in die
Gesellschaft wieder zurück also die
kommen ja nicht vom Mond oder irgendwie
so und ähm aber trotzdem war es
natürlich richtig von Akku zum Beispiel
dieses diesen Freifahrtschein in Uniform
wieder einzuführen das Soldaten wieder
in Uniform in Deutsche Bundesbahn
benutzen sie dadurch auch sichtbar
werden ich glaube aber dass wir diese
Trennung die eigentlich befürchtet
hatten mit Abschaffung mit Aussetzung
der Wehrpflicht gar nicht so sehr hatten
und wenn ich mit Bundeswehrsoldaten
Soldaten rede dann sind die für mich
immer Teil der Gesellschaft was soll das
auch anders sein ich ähm ein besonderer
Teil aber ähm sie leben nicht auf einem
anderen Stern und was wir erreichen
müssen dass sie stärker in den in den
das ist natürlich den Krieg erreicht
worden auch zum Gutteil dass sie stärker
in den politischen Diskurs kommen dass
die stärker in den Kurs
gesellschaftliche Eliten kommen Sie dann
eine große Rolle spielen in den
Wahlprogrammen dass wir die Frage
stellen welche Rolle spielt außen
Sicherheitspolitik bei den Parteien
nicht und die CDU war ja dann auch
ehrlich immer eine Partei der Bundeswehr
ob sie das immer so waren in den letzten
20 Jahren könnte man ein kleines
Fragezeichen machen und dann sehen wir
auch in der Frage wie weit die Politik
Politikerinnen und Politiker bereithält
für den Posten das
Verteidigungsministers die wirklich über
eine eine Fachkompetenz verfügt das
Personal von vielen Parteien ja auch
überschaubar sein und da müssen wir
glaube ich besser werden
noch mal den Blick auf die Ukraine
wenden wir haben
eine bewundernswerte Kampfmoral in der
Ukraine wir haben viel westliche
Unterstützung in der Ukraine was
Waffenlieferungen munitionslieferung
angeht und das ist auch natürlich
ausschlaggebend für das weitermachen und
durchhalten in der Ukraine nun ist
erneut in den letzten Tagen ein Manifest
des Friedens formuliert worden von Frau
Schwarzer und Frau Wagenknecht mit
vielen vielen Unterschriften inzwischen
200.000 Unterschriften innerhalb von
wenigen Tagen
darf man das von Seiten der Politik
ignorieren und wenn man Umfragen Glauben
schenken kann dann ist die Bevölkerung
in Deutschland was Waffenlieferungen und
sonstiges angeht ja durchaus gespalten
die ist gespalten und ich kann den
Wunsch nach Frieden auch unterschreiben
es ist nur leider ein völlig
unrealistisches Papier weil das geht
eben einseitig nicht es ist leider so
dass kriegt beginnen viel einfacher ist
als kriegt beenden das ist glaube wenn
Sie wahrscheinlich besser sagen als ich
als Militärhistoriker aber dass die
politische Realität
und gibt ja sehr viele Abhandlungen von
sehr vielen auch sehr unterschiedlichen
internationalen nationalen tun es ist
sehr schwer sich vorzustellen wie ein
dauerhafter Frieden in der Ukraine im
Moment möglich sein dann kann sie
waffenpausen vorstellen die aber
letztlich nur das Vorspiel für eine
weitere militärische Auseinandersetzung
sein würden deswegen ist es schwierig
und
ich kann mir gar keine Bundesregierung
Handlungen vorstellen die das Ergebnis
dass die sich wünschen herbei bringt
also ich kann auch mir wünschen dass
jeder in Deutschland Millionär ist aber
es haben legitimer Wunsch aber es wird
halt nicht so also
insofern und ich glaube dass wir das
mehr also ich bin ja Teil des Deutschen
Bundestages und
der für mich natürlich solche Gespräche
auch parteiübergreifen ich kenne
überhaupt niemand auch nicht in der
Ampel der sich auch nur einen Tag länger
wünscht die Kriege als als
es gibt keine kriegsfreudigkeit in der
Politik in keiner Partei meiner nicht
Wochen einen anderen nicht oder insofern
es gibt keine Mittel wie wir diesen
Frieden erzwingen können wir können die
Niederlage der Ukraine erzählen das
können wir machen das ist aber kein
Frieden
das kann man sich in wachmut und vielen
Städten schon kurzfristig dann angucken
was dann für diese wie viel tote wir
dann zu beklagen haben in der Ukraine
wenn es einen solchen
diktatfrieden gäbe und es würde
natürlich zu einer Instabilität in ganz
Europa führen
sind wir schnell dabei die
unterschriftler und diejenigen die das
Manifest geschrieben haben als Friedens
bewegte Fantasten abzutun
also es sind meine Sachen uns einige
Fantasten dabei aber das will ich jetzt
gar nicht despektierlich verstehen weil
viele von denen würden mich
wahrscheinlich als Polizist so
bezeichnen also wir sind in einer
liberalen Demokratie und da kann man
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein und wir
haben von Anfang an ein Teil der
Bevölkerung gehabt auch einen Teil jetzt
sind wir an alle schwarzer und Frau
Wagenknecht die also zu einem
politischen ist teppichment so gehören
die ganz anderer Meinung waren als die
allermeisten Experten und wenn ich mir
sehe die Sicherheitspolitiker mit
Ausnahme von
im Herrn Warwick sind alle unisono also
einer Meinung dass man die Ukraine
unterstützen muss und zwar sehr
weitgehend unterstützen muss also da ist
es eine erstaunliche Einigkeit in der
Community die sich wissenschaftlich mit
mit Sicherheitspolitik und mit kriegen
beschäftigen so trotzdem kann man
anderer Meinung sein ich halte das so
völlig legitim ich habe mich auch mit
Frau Käßmann am Anfang des Krieges mal
unterhalten der Podiumsdiskussion und
sagte Frau okay Mann ich bin nicht ihrer
Meinung aber natürlich ist es völlig
legitim was sie äußern und ich habe auch
gar nichts dagegen aus dem Herzen
sozusagen ja und und das ist natürlich
ein ein Abwägen ist zwischen
Sicherheit und Frieden also welches gut
sitze ich eigentlich hören also mein
Vorwurf gegen dieses jetzt dieses neue
Manifest ist eigentlich also ich habe
gar nichts dagegen wenn man sagt wir
müssen doch mehr und mehr
Friedensverhandlungen führen und
dergleichen ich mein Argument wäre das
macht man nicht im offenen also
natürlich breite die die Bundesregierung
kam vielleicht waffenlie Übung verkünden
wenn sie dann getätigt worden sind aber
sie kann natürlich nicht verkünden
welche Kompromisse sie vielleicht in
Erwägung zieht um einen solchen Krieg zu
beenden also so läuft Diplomatie nicht
und mein Argument war immer also ich
weiß nicht unser Botschafter in Moskau
dieser von Geier der wird ja wohl nicht
in der Nase bohren da in Moskau also
natürlich passieren da Gespräche im
Hintergrund versucht man Dinge
auszudrucken auch über Drittstaaten
haben wenn man einen Punkt ist dass man
in den Manifest gibt es auch darum dass
man die Waffenlieferung stoppen soll und
da wird dann meine Sachen wenn man das
tut
dann ist wenn das der gesamte Westen tut
inklusive der USA und dann ist es halt
in drei Monaten dieser Krieg vorbei und
hat Putin gewonnen und das müssen sich
diejenigen Unterzeichner eben klar
machen sagen ja wir wollen den Krieg
beenden auch wenn es dann am Anfang
nicht so klingt letztlich auf Kosten der
Ukraine wir tauschen den Frieden den wir
wollen hier in unseren schönen
bürgerlichen Wohnungen wir wollen nicht
weiter belastet werden auch natürlich
das ethische Problem ist sterben sehr
viele Menschen wir wollen davon nicht
belastet werden und dann soll die
Ukraine halt untereinander russischen
Besatzung darauf läuft ja letztlich
hinaus auch wenn es nicht so Express ist
da steht und da
würde ich mal sagen Leute also das kann
man vielleicht nicht ethisch verstehen
dass man sagt wir wollen nicht wollen
dass es töten endet aber ähm
was wird dagegen eingetauscht und da bin
ich mit deiner Heimat einer Meinung also
und praktisch fast alle
Sicherheitspolitiker auch die sich damit
wissenschaftlich beschäftigen
leider ist es so kann ich ja wieder als
das Drucker sprechen dass man Kriege in
der Regel nicht am Verhandlungstisch
beendet und es wäre schön wenn das viele
mal begreifen würden sondern die meisten
Kriege werden auf dem Schlachtfeld
entschieden auch wenn wir das nicht
wahrhaben wollen wenn es zu unserer für
unsere Ethik nicht passt wenn man meint
ja der zweite Weltkrieg aber ganz viele
andere Konflikte schauen wir mal auch
Afghanistan die Taliban haben letztlich
diesen Krieg in die Länge gezogen und
haben ihn letztlich auf dem Schlachtfeld
entschieden die Verhandlungen Doha sind
gar nicht entscheidend gewesen und das
natürlich Diplomatie immer eine Rolle
spielt in Kriegen aber Beendigung das
ist eine Binse aber
einige Menschen versuchen verzweifelt
die Logik von Kriegen die natürlich
schrecklich ist
wegzudeklinieren und zu meinen mit
Friedensverhandlungen würden die meisten
kriegen sagen nein ist leider nicht so
und ich glaube dass die dass wir nur
eine Chance haben aus meiner Sicht da
kann man dagegen sein diesen Krieg zu
beenden oder zumindest einzufrieren wenn
Putin erkennt er kommt militärisch nicht
weiter und deswegen werden ein Plädoyer
die Ukraine weiter und schneller und
umfassender meditierisch zu unterstützen
sonst wird irgendwann die russische
Fahne in Kiel
Olaf Scholz hat immer gesagt dass man
auch gleichzeitig die Gesprächskanäle
offen halten sollte auch wenn man Waffen
liefert ist das richtig das zu tun ja
ich würde sogar weitergehen sagen wir
müssen ganz wachsam sein um kleinste
Chancen zu erkennen
das ist eine Veränderung in der
Einstellung der Russen
gibt die diesen Krieg angefangen haben
und die deswegen Ihnen auch irgendwie
beenden müssen die Ukraine den Krieg
angefangen
und das ein Mittel ist Diplomatie ein
Mittel ist dass es Gesprächskontakte
gibt
sonst kriegt man ja gar nicht mit ob es
vielleicht Veränderung gibt aber bisher
ist die Nachrichtenlage völlig eindeutig
es gibt keine Veränderungen auf der
russischen Seite sondern es gibt naja
wir haben unsere Ziele nicht erreicht
dann müssen wir halt den Einsatz erhöhen
und das hat Russland jetzt schon
mehrfach gemacht und der Westen hat
immer dann seinerseits den Einsatz
erhöht und ich glaube wenn ich mir etwas
wünschen würde dann wünsche ich mir eine
tragie Aussage der EZB whatever it takes
Liebe Russland wir werden reagieren wir
sind wirtschaftlich und politisch dazu
in der Lage und wollen das auch ähm das
wird dann hoffentlich irgendwann in
Russland dazu führen dass sie diesen
Krieg nicht gewinnen können und dann
kommt der Raum und dann ist es wie sie
sagen militärisch entschieden weil sie
militärisch nicht gewinnen können und
dann kommen wir vielleicht in ein
Fenster wo wir Friedensverhandlungen
sinnvollen Erfolg führen können aber
solange ist diese Einsicht in Russland
nicht gibt
und leider ist es sicher nicht die
Intention und ich würde den auch kein
Vorwurf machen es gehört in einer
pluralistisch oder gut in der
pluralistischen Gesetz dass jede
denkbare Meinung irgendwie von jemandem
geäußert wird und ich einfach
unterdrückt wird aber umso mehr Leute
diesen Brief unterschreiben und so
größer wird die Hoffnung in Russland
sein naja irgendwann wird der Westen
aufhören die Ukraine zu unterstützen
haben wir ja doch gewonnen und wenn es
dann zwischendurch eine halbe Million
Tote gegeben hat dann ist das eben so
aber dann haben wir unser Ziel doch
erreicht und wir somit den Kopf durch
die Wand will dem können wir das nicht
gestatten weil dann fängt China in
Taiwan an und Russland in Moldau wo
fängt es eigentlich an und wo hört das
auf einen Punkt ich glaube den den Sie
gesagt haben unterstreichen ich glaube
nicht das Putin glaubt dass er mit
seinem militärischen Möglichkeiten am
Ende ist im Gegenteil wir haben eine
mobil machen gesehen die ähm besser
gelaufen ist aus russischer Sicht als
wir es vielleicht manchmal dargestellt
haben bei allen Problemen die sie haben
und ich glaube was wir eben zu wenig
sehen ist sind die doch nicht
unerheblichen Probleme der Ukraine die
eben auch sehr hohe verlusteten und die
deren Armee auch geschwächt ist das hält
die Ukraine sehr hinterher würde ich
gerne wie verlässlich sind denn die
Zahlen auch das was Putin sagt und das
was er uns als Propaganda
Krieg ist so ein Geheimnis und natürlich
zahlen das ist ganz schwer verurteilen
also die die die also ich würde mal
sagen die Verlustzahlen der Ukraine
weiß ich nicht ob wer das eigentlich am
besten überhaupt wirklich wirklich weiß
ähm
die Ukraine sind ich höre
außerordentlich zurückhaltend damit und
die Verlustzahlen der Russen da gibt's
sicherlich Schätzungen die sind aber
sehr sehr vage und das wundert mich
nicht denn die Frage ist ob die großen
so genau selbst wissen zählen denn die
Wagner Leute ihre Toten ist zum Beispiel
die große Frage nicht also da wird man
nicht mit einer gewichteten Matrix
zählen also das ist außerordentlich
schwierig solche Zahlen gar nicht
richtig kennen inwiefern kennen wir denn
dann wirklich den Status Quo des Krieges
auf dem wir ja dann letztendlich unsere
Entscheidung aufstellen müssen
vor allen Dingen müssen wir nichts wir
haben alle natürlich also der BND weiß
mehr als wir beide hier oder auf jeden
Fall als ich aber sie haben natürlich
als Bundestagsabgeordneten noch andere
Möglichkeiten aber wenn man mal den
anderen kenne ich dann auch sieht dann
ist das relativ begrenzt Russland haben
wir natürlich eine besseres Bild weil es
da eine Aufklärung gibt das eigentliche
Problem ist die Ukraine weil wir weil
ukrainische generalstoff soweit ich das
weiß nun mit den deutschen Behörden
nicht seine Angriffspläne teilt sondern
mit den USA vor allen Dingen aber solche
Einschätzungen sind enorm schwer es ist
enorm schwer zu tun und allein die Frage
was produzieren die Russen was haben die
großen was können sie beweglich machen
da gibt's schon Einschätzungen davon
deswegen macht man ja sie haben so
ungefähr die Hälfte ihre Panzer verloren
und so aber wie genau das ist ist eben
enorm schwer und ähm ein Stück weit
absolute Heilmann dass wir darauf auf
diesen nicht wissen letztendlich auch
unsere Entscheidung stützen wir wissen
ja etwas sie wissen nämlich dass
dass die Annahme am Anfang ja war die
Ukraine kann dem keine vier Wochen
standhalten und das ist dann um falsch
und dann dann ist so der umgekehrte
Eindruck entstanden naja dieses publikel
kleine Russland das kann ja militärisch
nicht durchhalten also von der Annahme
kann man einfach nicht ausgehen und es
ist eigentlich auch egal ob Sie jetzt
50% ihrer Panzer oder 30 oder sogar 60
verloren haben sie sind als doch dann
relativ große Volkswirtschaft mit 153
Millionen Einwohnern natürlich in der
Lage diesen Krieg auch noch fünf sechs
sieben Jahre weiter zu führen
und
dazu sind sie auch politisch
offensichtlich bereit und auch ihre
Bevölkerung gegenüber
bereits ich will das mal umgekehrt sagen
wenn sie sich mal die übermachte
Alliierten gegenüber Nazi Deutschland
angucken dann hat Deutschland das
verdammt lange durchgehalten
leider weil wenn man ja früher den Krieg
hätte beenden können dann in 20
Millionen Tote weniger zu beklagen
gewesen es ist alles andere als eine
Kleinigkeit gewesen aber auch musste
erst die Atombombe fallen so ist es
insofern müssen wir davon ausgehen das
ist es dann ein Umdenken in Russland
gibt wenn die sagen wir können das noch
viele Jahre führen und auch viele Jahre
die Ressourcen haben wir gewinnen aber
trotzdem nicht
und deswegen gibt es auch immer diese
vorsichtige Formulierung die Ukraine
darf nicht verlieren weil was ist
eigentlich gewinnen die Ukraine wie
Russland all ihren tun rausschmeißt wenn
die da weiter eine
russische ukrainischen Grenze stehen und
ständig mit
Angriffskrieg Drohnen das ist ja dann
wie so ein Israel parisellenischer
Konflikte hört ja nie auf aber wenn Sie
wenn Sie sagen die Russen sind bereit
ist noch x Jahre weiter zu führen wie
lange ist denn der Westen bereit das
weiter zu machen wie lang kann der
Westen weitermachen
unser Engel also wir machen wir fangen
jetzt nicht an wir wollen es nicht
eskalieren aber wir halten der Sache so
lange stand wie die andere Seite macht
umso mehr umso überzeugende sagen
umso eher wird es ein Umdenken geben und
umso mehr wir sagen mal so ein halbes
Jahr oder vielleicht nicht umso mehr
entsteht ja auf der gegenüberliegenden
Seite die Hoffnung ist doch noch zu
gewinnen weil es ja nicht nur eine
rechthaberfrage ist
sozusagen mich beeint sehen zu können
das ist irgendwie militärischen
weiterhin auf Erfolg war sondern es ist
ja auch innenpolitisch für Russland viel
einfacher zu sagen ja länger aber dann
erreichen unsere Ziele ja doch
Herr stoltenberger hat heute gesagt dass
die munitionierung die der besten
überhaupt zur Verfügung stellen kann
irgendwann nicht mehr ausreichend ist
und das viel zu wenig Munition
produziert wird
zeigt das dass der besten da jetzt schon
so langsam an Grenzen stößt ja ich
glaube dass die
mindset die Seitenwände insgesamt in der
Europäischen Union noch nicht so richtig
angekommen ist und das ist ja nicht nur
ein Problem Deutschlands die glaube ich
im Bereich der Zeiten wenn im
Wesentlichen verlorenes Jahr hatten wenn
wir die Zeit am Ende definieren
Einsatzbereitschaft
Bereitschaft herzustellen also auch
Bereich munitionsproduktion das ist ja
alles im Schneckentempo geschehen aber
es gilt eben nicht nur für Deutschland
und auch für andere Länder die Briten
machen tolle Pressekonferenzen und
treten da irgendwie fancy auf aber wenn
man ihre eigenen Fähigkeiten sitzen die
eben auch sehr begrenzt und ich glaube
dass alle irgendwie gehofft haben naja
jetzt liefern wir da so ein paar Panzer
und oder ein paar bisschen Munition und
so weiter und dann ist es irgendwie
vorbei und einige haben wir auch den
Begriff der Kriegswirtschaft mal
eingebracht aber da ist eben viel zu
wenig passiert und das geht eben nicht
nur für Deutschland
wozu wenig passiert ist sondern das gilt
für viele andere Länder auch ich meine
die die Niederländer haben immer
Munition bestellt aber wir sind nach wie
vor als Europa
keinen wesentlichen Schritt
vorangekommen wir haben wir streiten uns
bei der Panzer Produktion wer soll was
bauen bei Produktion von Flugzeugen es
ist ein
sicherheitspolitisch trotz aller
Einigkeit bei Sanktionen in den großen
Fragen relativ zerstrittener Haufen und
man würde hoffen als teilende Beobachter
dass der Druck dieses Krieges ausreicht
um die großen sicherheitspolitischen
Probleme Europas mal wirklich zu lösen
da sind wir aber nicht wirklich
weitergekommen und
da kann man irgendwie nur sagen das
deutet ja so die Äußerung an diese
zitiert haben dass Europa jetzt im
Bereich der Rüstungsproduktion den
Schuss noch nicht richtig gehört hat
weil man sie haben es eben schon so ein
Stück weit angedeutet aber wenn man
Putin jetzt so betrachtet und sie sagen
dass das auch durchaus Jahre
weitergehen kann ist das dann so eine
Ziel
fortführungslogik die da entsteht
ich glaube leider ja also
wir können schon die Frage ja nicht
beantworten aber mit heutigen Wissen ein
Jahr nach Kriegsbeginn den Krieg
angefangen hätte wenn er gewusst hätte
was er da hingeht
nehmen wir mal optimistisch an er würde
es nicht anfangen jetzt hat er ihn aber
angefangen jetzt ist er ja sozusagen so
weit vorangegangen ist ja wie in jedem
Konflikt dann ist ja die Frage für ihn
wie komme ich denn da jetzt wieder raus
sehr schwierig zu beantworten und
das Bundestagsabgeordneter darf man ja
bestimmte Geheimdienst Studien lesen und
so wir können auch entsprechend
aber
man kann im Ergebnis sagen wir haben an
gar keiner Stelle und von keinem Dienst
dessen Erkenntnisse mir jedenfalls in
Teilen bekannt sind irgendein Hinweis
darauf dass es da irgendein wackeln auf
russischer Seite gibt es auch damit zu
tun dass Putin hier eine Gesichtswahrung
nach außen hin
einfach fortführen will wir haben eine
diktatorische System bei dem die die
Mafia um Putin herum das Land unter
jocht hat und wie im Iran auch ein
natürliches Interesse daran hat ihre
Macht zu erhalten jetzt sind sie einen
Schritt gegangen in der Ukraine der ihm
sicher auch weh tut an verschiedenen
Stellen die sind sie aber gegangen aber
sie können macht politisch jetzt auch
nicht so ohne weiteres wieder zurück
und das wollen sie glaube ich auch nicht
und
ich frage mich immer glauben die das
eigentlich selber was sie da erzählen
das frage ich mich ein bisschen Iran
auch also ich meine ein System das eine
muslimische oder islamische Revolution
angefangen hat hatten als engsten
Kooperationspartner eine krasse
islamfeindliche System wie Russland das
passt ja alles überhaupt nicht zusammen
außer im Sinne von macht er halt
hat Hitler selber geglaubt dass er da
erzählt hat und
also wir wissen es nicht so ganz genau
aber wahrscheinlich ist sicher das ist
geglaubt hat aber Klapper putin ist es
so eine so eine Frage und uns fällt es
natürlich schwer diesen Krieg aus mit
der Logik von Putin zu betrachten ich
habe aber ich glaube also ich kann auch
noch Rätselraten aber ich glaube aus
seiner Sicht wenn man mal diese Logik
annimmt den Ukraine diese Staat gibt es
gar nicht ähm der Westen bedroht uns und
wir müssen uns dann erhalten nicht
dieses Versprechen
das in die Vergangenheit geht hat er
keinen zukunftsversprechen und daraus
folgt ja eigentlich immer nur wie soll
Putin da wieder was sie sagen daraus
kommt er kann eigentlich nur mit einer
einem Ergebnis einem Zwischenergebnis
zumindest rauskommen dass eben eine
gewichtswahrung wart und das ist
mindestens die Eroberung Provinzen und
die große Frage die wir haben deswegen
dachte ich auch wir wissen nichts die
Frage was wahnsinnig schwer
einzuschätzen ist welche Kampfkraft hat
die russischen Stärke noch haben was
haben die noch im
ärmer
findest du trotzdem muss man als Westen
dann ja auch eine Position haben wie
weit gehen wir und wie lange machen wir
das mit und wie wird der Westen dann
letztendlich weitergehen wird der Westen
dann irgendwann sagen so jetzt sind wir
an dem Punkt Liebe Ukrainer auch wenn es
hier kein Diktat Frieden sonst irgendwas
gibt dass man sagen muss jetzt müsst ihr
euch aber auch ein Stück weit bewegen
und jetzt setzen wir uns mal an dem
Verhandlungstisch oder wie kann sowas
aussehen welche Bewegungen wollen wir
denn genau von der Ukraine also was ist
die Bewegung die Ukraine nicht einen
Millimeter unseres Landes wird
preisgegeben gibt es da vielleicht eine
Kompromisslinie die da heißt der dann
jetzt vielleicht doch an Russland und
sonst nicht die Position von Russland
zu sagen das würde uns genügen und
solange wir das nicht haben kann man das
von der Ukraine auch nicht verlangen
also die
Diplomatie wird schon die
Verhandlungstaktik hinbekommen für einen
logischen Frieden es gibt aber keinen
logischen Frieden das ist ja das Problem
und
[Musik]
insbesondere müssen wir uns als Westen
fragen wenn wann immer wir irgendeine
Form von Frieden Ukraine und wie genau
der auch immer Aussehen Magazin wir
werden die Ukraine so hochrüsten müssen
und das wird ja auch enorme Aufwand sein
das dass sie dass sie sich so stark
werden können das ist völlig
ausgeschlossen ist das Russland das
erneut versucht
und das möchte ich mir alles mal
vorstellen dagegen ist die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft ja eher ein kleinere
Übung jetzt nur finanziell gesprochen
wenn wir das sehen dass die Beziehung zu
Russland und das Vertrauen zu Russland
ja komplett zerstört ist auf welcher
Basis könnte man sich denn überhaupt
eine Friedensordnung vorstellen allein
auf auf den Punkt Abschreckung
das ist wirklich überhaupt noch nicht
abzusehen weil ich würde meinen
historischen Vergleich bemühen wir sind
praktisch
im Jahre 1915 im April die ersten
offensiven sind gescheiter jeder
Rätselraten wie soll das weitergehen es
gab auch erste Friedens Fühler die
ausgestreckt wurden und jetzt versuchen
wir von 1915 auf die Zeit nach dem
Ersten Weltkrieg zu schauen das war aus
der Perspektive 15 fast unmöglich und
meine heute wissen willst wie es
ausgegangen ist aber wir müssten ja
dafür beurteilen können und nicht gut
aber wir könnten um Ihre Frage zu
beantworten müssten wir ja wissen wie
Ende dieser Krieg wie lange dauert er
welche Wunden reist er auch militärisch
dauert dann noch ein Jahr noch zehn
Jahre und zunächst geht es glaube ich
darum irgendwann hoffentlich diesen
Krieg überhaupt zu beenden und auch der
Gedanke
überhaupt denken haben wir nicht ein
unendlich lang langen Konflikt der
vielleicht mal hoch und runter sind und
wir am besten wissen wollen jetzt
Frieden und du musst es abgeschlossen
sein da kann man zu anderen Dingen
kümmern aber das ist überhaupt nicht
Interesse Putins und ich würde gerne die
große Gefahr wäre wenn Putin jetzt ein
Waffenstillstand anbietet und sagt so
wenn er vielleicht doch den da was
erobert und sagt so jetzt ist Schluss
dann wird das große Diskussionen geben
im Westen genau ja jetzt müssen wir mit
Moskau doch verhandeln dann liegt das
auf dem Tisch was heißt das und so
weiter aber solange das nicht der Fall
ist es alles Spekulation 1915 wenn Sie
das Zitieren das war aber Weltkrieg
befinden wir uns im Weltkrieg und das
ist auch genau der Punkt wo viele
Friedens bewegte dann sagen dass eine
Eskalationsspirale die wollen wir nicht
noch mal sehen das ist richtig insofern
ist der Vergleich und 1915 ähm will soll
natürlich nicht sagen dass wir ähm
selber Kriegspartei sind und es ist ein
anderer Krieg auch natürlich gewesen nur
so als Vergleich ich habe das im
Vergleich genommen weil es so wahnsinnig
schwer ist da Voraussagen zu treffen
also ich glaube ich sehe überhaupt nicht
irgendeine Bereitschaft irgendeines
westlichen Landes Truppen zu schicken
und das ist die entscheidende
völkerrechtliche Grenze alles andere
würde ich nicht ausschließen wollen also
ob wir Kampfflugzeuge oder was der
Teufel was weil das hängt ja auch davon
ab was Russland irgendwie einsetzt aber
ich glaube nehme ein ganz klaren
politischen Willen da wir wollen nicht
Kriegspartei werden
ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen
irgendwelche Bedingungen dass ich daran
sagen irgendwas
sagen die Beendigung des Ersten
Weltkrieges in dieser Art und Weise war
die Grundlage für den zweiten weltkriegt
und dieser Frieden ist doch teuer
verkauft worden
sind seine Chance hatte in der Zeit
zwischen den Weltkriegen der da ist er
auch noch mal von Marc ist gar keine
Frage aber
das war eine andere wichtiger Punkt
trotzdem die Schlussfrage wenn wir
diesen Krieg jetzt uns anschauen das
Vertrauen zu Russland komplett zerstört
etc wird auf am Ende dieses krises ein
nächster langer Kalter Krieg folgen
das kann man also ich wünsche es mir
natürlich nicht Russland wird ja
geografisch immer unser Nachbar bleiben
und ich hoffe dass wir irgendwann also
putin ist 70 der wird ja jetzt nicht
noch mal 70 Jahre regieren das glaube
ich kann man medizinisch ausschließen
ja das sind aber noch zehn Jahre und
nicht noch 70 Jahre das ist ja
historisch deutlich weniger
und ich glaube wir haben insofern
hoffentlich gelernt dass wir dann bereit
sind auch einen Krieg kriegerischen
ergressor gegenüber einem Land das dann
Schluss macht so zu helfen das ist in
eine bessere Phase kommt aber das alles
Zukunftsmusik ich bin optimistisch dass
es irgendwann passieren wird ob es
kurzfristig passieren würde mich eher
vorsichtiger mit meinem Optimismus
ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich für diese
Diskussion hier am Tisch und ich bedanke
mich bei Ihnen sehr herzlich fürs
zuschauen morgen um 22:15 Uhr sehen Sie
die Phönix Runde an dieser Stelle und
ich wünsche noch einen schönen Abend bei
Felix
[Musik]